this can't be a thing that people did
this cannot Oh Thanksgiving a time for
family togetherness and of course food
let's start off our Thanksgiving feast
with a delicious cranberry souffle salad
mix gelatin and water add mayonnaise
walnuts and apples
don't forget the cranberry sauce pour
into a cake pan and chill until set now
you're ready to enjoy
what is it me that should be a game show
is it me it's a pureed brain the way
that it moves terrifies me let's do it
Oh I try not to throw up in my mouth
right now it's like baby food next up we
have this mouth-watering orange mallow
yet been arranged yams and orange slices
in a shallow baking dish sprinkle with
brown sugar and bake then top with
marshmallows and bake again until Brown
oh yeah I'm already into this like this
looks appetizing
this is a classic right yeah can you get
it good and it smells really good
there's oranges in here oranges yeah I'm
down yeah that's not supposed to happen
the potatoes nice not a fan of the
orange I don't know if I've ever had
like a cooked orange it's like a
breakfast you'd make for yourself if you
were really hungover it's not working
it's like a bad melted flavor of ice
cream to me it just seems like you want
it doesn't belong let's have some hot
dr. pepper bring a pot of dr. pepper to
a boil
spoon into a glass and garnish with a
lemon slice that's all there is to it
look at these fancy goblets
I hope there's whiskey in this Cheers
everything something what is that I
don't know man I like it this would
actually like warm your soul is this hot
kool-aid is this hot dr. pepper I don't
hate this oh so happy I'm drinking our
dr. pepper it does taste like a vintage
ad looks I will do this I will make this
and bring it places hmm it's time for
some yummy spam birds who needs a turkey
when you have spam cut the spam into
slices fill with stuffing and close them
up with toothpicks broil them in the
oven until crispy and serve come
exciting's I've never had spam before
I've only heard about it you didn't get
any greens Oh
oh man
that's great you're going through a
really big moment right I'm going there
big one now a spam fan mm that's bad I
love it look a reverse hotdog look Yeah
right inside I'm all slimy now I know
it's very greasy like our fingers are
glistening right now didn't this remind
you thanks guys I want to go and eat
more spam finally we have frozen jelly
Turkey vegetable salad mix gelatin and
water then add cream of celery soup
combined with mixed vegetables and diced
Turkey a little mayonnaise brings it all
together then it's ready to pour into a
mold and chill until firm
oh god oh no this is like a cruel joke
cuz I thought I was cake and it's not
cake it looks like a reindeer took a
[ __ ] it looks like it used to slither
there's some sort of meat in there it
does seem like it's me oh no one wants a
waffle we've got some heft to it and I'm
not gonna watch it hit the plate I can't
oh I can smell it there's absolutely
nothing good about this just kind of
like the sandwich get some bread on each
side I don't hate this
honestly I don't hate this at all I'm
still chewing it you know I don't know
why people love jello and putting things
in it that don't belong that well that
was quite a feast wasn't it thank you
for joining us and we'll see you next
time
[Music]